[Musik]
massenpanik im iran bei den
trauerfeierlichkeiten für den getöteten
general zu le manie sterben mindestens
50 menschen reaktion auf krise am golf
die bundeswehr zieht sicherheitshalber
soldaten aus dem irak ab und verlegt sie
in nachbarländern und der torwart titan
zurück bei bayern münchen oliver kahn
ist jetzt offiziell im vorstand des
rekordmeisters
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem dienstag norbert lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den sport einen schönen
doch von mir wieder beginnen wir mit
iran angeblich hat die führung dort 13
pläne ausgearbeitet um sich an den usa
zu rechnen
selbst der schwächste davon wäre ein
historischer albtraum zitiert eine
iranische agentur den sicherheitschef
die beerdigung des von den usa getöteten
generals wird von einer massenpanik
überschattet mit mindestens 56 toten und
200 verletzten aus teheran der branche
ging den sack general solle man es mit
einem gewaltigen aufmarsch an
trauergästen
auch hier wie an den tagen zuvor drängen
sich zehntausende um abschied zu nehmen
dem neuen nationalen märtyrer nahe zu
sein und dann passiert es eine
massenpanik bricht aus zahlreiche
menschen werden totgetrampelt oder
verletzt der leiter des nationalen
rettungsdienstes muss stündlich die
opferzahlen im staatsfernsehen nach oben
korrigieren am morgen hatte irans
parlamente ein erneutes wütendes
vergeltungs signal richtung usa gesendet
es verabschiedete mehrere neue anti
terror gesetze die ermordung soliman es
gilt nun als ein akt amerikanischen
staatsterrorismus und rechtfertigt
gegenmaßnahmen wir haben nun auch das
verteidigungsministerium als terror
organisation anerkannt außerdem alle die
am befehl general salomoni zu töten
beteiligt waren
damit sind der verteidigungsminister und
präsident trump terroristen und müssen
bestraft werden
ist diese entscheidung eher symbolisch
hat eine andere durchaus praktischen
nutzen außerdem verabschiedete das
parlament einen sonder etat in höhe von
200 millionen euro für die
revolutionsgarden unter anderem für die
geplanten vergeltungsschläge gegen die
amerikaner hätte das von sanktionen
gebeutelte volk sonst gegen noch mehr
geld fürs militär protestiert hofft
irans führung nun offenbar dass diese
entscheidung im zuge des nationalen
ausnahmezustands hingenommen wird
die beerdigung soll in mannis wurde
wegen des tragischen zwischenfalls auf
den abend verschoben wo und wie der iran
vergeltung üben will ist völlig offen
der general wurde im irak getötet von
dort hat die bundeswehr jetzt aus
sicherheitsgründen fast ein viertel
ihrer soldaten ausgeflogen
im rahmen des internationalen einsatzes
gegen den es waren bisher 150 bundeswehr
soldaten im irak vor allem um dort
irakische truppen auszubilden
die 32 intouch ii stationierten
deutschen wurden zu einem stützpunkt in
jordanien gebracht drei weitere von
bagdad nach kuwait das größte kontingent
bleibt allerdings in erbil im autonomen
kurdengebiet cornelia schiemenz hat
details plötzlich ging alles ganz
schnell
mit einem a400m werden in der nacht
kurzfristig deutsche soldaten aus dem
zentraliran abgeholt sie landen am
morgen auf der jordanischen militärbasis
als rack östlich von ammann hier sind
sie in sicherheit
sie sind dort erst einmal stand bei auch
aus sicherheitsgründen und werden
tagesaktuell entscheiden wie sich die
dinge weiterentwickeln werden es dabei
bleibt im parlament und regierung keine
ausländischen streitkräfte mehr im irak
haben wollen dann wird es auch keine
deutschen soldatinnen und soldaten im
irak mehr geben können der großteil der
deutschen soldaten und soldatinnen ist
noch im irak im relativ sicheren erbil
hier bildet die bundeswehr seit jahren
kurdische peschmerga im kampf gegen den
es aus mit dem teilabzug steht
deutschland nicht alleine da andere
staaten bereiten gleiche maßnahmen vor
für die nächsten tage
ergreifen gleiche maßnahmen insofern
bewegen wir uns hier auch im
internationalen gleichklang die
verteidigungsministerin macht deutlich
der kampf gegen den es werde weiter
gehen alle diplomatischen kanäle sollen
genutzt werden um die situation zu
entspannen
das braucht eine sondersitzung des
sicherheitsrats der vereinten nationen
und sind enttäuscht darüber dass
bundesaußenminister heiko maas das
bisher nicht veranlasst hat wir haben
einen sitz als deutschland im
sicherheitsrat dann sollten wir noch
nutzen
der appell von experten es reiche nicht
aus nur die iranische seite zur mäßigung
aufzufordern die ermordung des
iranischen generals lima nie und eines
hochrangigen irakischen kommandeurs ist
ein klarer bruch des völkerrechtes und
das muss man auch klar und deutlich
benennen auch seitens der
bundesregierung geschieht das nicht dann
läuft man gefahr am ende doch eine
amerikanische politik mitzutragen die
zum krieg führen kann
die lage im irak ist angespannt oberste
priorität habe die sicherheit der
soldaten so das versprechen der
bundesregierung und dann nachmittag hat
dann auch die nato bekannt gegeben dass
sie einen teil ihrer soldaten aus dem
irak abziehen
berlin in brüssel ist das jetzt das ende
der nato mission gegen den 1
darauf hat nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg heute in einem gespräch mit
dem irakischen premierminister noch
einmal großen wert gelegt er sagte die
nato mission die irakischen militärs und
polizisten ausbildet sei ein sehr
wichtiges element im kampf gegen den us
und gegen den internationalen
terrorismus und sie werde nicht
abgebrochen sondern aus
sicherheitsgründen unterbrochen
die mission besteht aus circa 500
soldatinnen und soldaten vorwiegend aus
kanada der türkei und spanien
die nun teilweise in die nachbarländer
kuwait und jordanien verlegt werden mehr
details wollte die nato aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht mitteilen
man bleibe aber mit der irakischen
regierung weiter in engem kontakt also
kein rauswurf der nato aus dem irak auch
kein abbruch des anti terror kampfes
aber doch ein sehr bedenklicher hinweis
auf die äußerst angespannte
sicherheitslage
wie schön für diese einschätzung aus
brüssel gegen den nec drohungen und
gegen drohungen was könnten etwa die usa
tun um eine weitere verschärfung der
situation zu verhindern
antworten dazu gibt es auch auf heute.de
im interview mit dem experten christian
mölling vom forschungsinstitut der
deutschen gesellschaft für auswärtige
politik
in madrid ist eine lange zeit der
politischen blockade zu ende spaniens
parlament hat einen regierungschef
gewählt
alte und neue ministerpräsident ist
pedro sanchez der sozialist gewannen die
entscheidende abstimmung ganz knapp mit
den stimmen seines neuen
koalitionspartners der links partei
podemos um fabio iglesias zuvor hatte
sanchez einen deal mit den katalanischen
separatisten ausgehandelt die partei hat
sich bei der wahl heute enthalten
annemarie arendt berichtet er hat es
geschafft mit gerade mal zwei stimmen
vorsprung
pedro sanchez chef der sozialisten soll
künftig spanien regieren
zusammen mit seinem ehemaligen rivalen
dem linksbündnis podemos ein neustart
nach monatelanger politischer blockade
ich vertraue darauf dass wir nun den
streit überwinden können und die
spannungen die im parlament herrschen
wir brauchen jetzt verständnis konsens
und absprachen
das ist wichtig für unser land und
unsere mitbürger ihnen ist die wahl zu
verdanken den katalanischen separatisten
sie haben sich heute enthalten und damit
sanchez den weg geebnet dafür musste er
ihnen einen dialog über die
unabhängigkeit kataloniens zu sagen
nicht wenige sehen den deal kritisch
[Applaus]
darauf ankommen was die regierung so
macht ich habe da so meine zweifel
ich finde es gut dass wir nun endlich
eine regierung haben aber mal sehen wie
das so wird mit dieser koalition und den
verhandlungen mit den unabhängigkeit
befürworter der ministerpräsident will
mit dem neuen linksbündnis den
mindestlohn erhöhen verspricht mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit doch sein
politischer spielraum ist begrenzt die
regierung braucht die unterstützung der
anderen parteien um gesetze überhaupt
durchzubringen
es gibt eine starke polarisierung das
macht die einigung zwischen dem linken
und dem rechten flügel sehr schwierig
nur mit vielen zugeständnissen hat er
sein ziel erreicht und die nächsten
bewährungsproben stehen schon an die
abstimmung über den haushalt und der
dialog mit den katalanen
auch österreich hat eine neue regierung
zum ersten mal ein bündnis aus
konservativen und grünen und zum ersten
mal hat das kabinett mehr frauen als
männer in der hofburg vereidigte
bundespräsident van der bellen die neue
mannschaft mit dem alten und neuen
kanzler sebastian kurz seine ovp stellt
zehn der insgesamt 14 ministerinnen und
minister zentrale regierungsziele sind
der klimaschutz und der kampf gegen
illegale migration regieren wollen
künftig auch die deutschen grünen und
arbeiten an ihrem programm auf der
klausur in hamburg stand die
wirtschaftspolitik ganz vorn
die industrie soll klimafreundlich
werden beim umbau müsse der staat
branchen helfen die besonders viel
energie benötigen und er soll finanziell
gerechter zugehen mit einem deutlich
höheren mindestlohn und mindest
honoraren für selbstständige patricia
wiedemeier berichtet
sie wollen die partei inhaltlich und
strukturell breiter aufstellen über die
themen umwelt und klimaschutz hinaus
zwei tage lang beriet der bundesvorstand
der grünen darüber wie die wirtschaft
umgebaut wie sie klimaneutral werden
kann
weniger bürokratie mehr kapital für
startups und förderung von erneuerbaren
energien das ist das ziel in diesem
jahrzehnt neu im sinne einer sozial
ökologischen marktwirtschaft und dafür
braucht sie klare politische leitplanken
damit es planungssicherheit gibt gerade
für innovation das hamburger start up a
connect hat zum beispiel ein verfahren
entwickelt bei dem metallteile mit
textil stoffen verschweißt werden
diese können dann in schiffe eingebaut
werden durch den stoff wird das gewicht
und so auch der co2 ausstoß reduziert
investitionen in saubere technologien
genau das wollen die grünen künftig
fördern
das akquirieren von kapital gerade für
solche ich sag mal hardware produkte ist
in deutschland extrem schwierig die
wirtschaft soll klimafreundlicher die
arbeitswelt sozial gerechter werden die
grünen fordern unter anderem einen
mindestlohn von 12 euro
zuverdienstmöglichkeiten für hartz iv
bezieher die aufwertung von
pflegeberufen konkrete maßnahmen zur
bekämpfung dieses niedriglohnsektors um
den menschen teil am wohlstand dieses
landes zu geben und um vertrauen in die
in die ferne ist der demokratie zu
ermöglichen
dass die grünen in hamburg getagt haben
dass die grüne spitzenkandidatin
fegebank immer mit dabei war kein zufall
im februar wird in der hansestadt
gewählt und jetzt zur diskussion um eine
mögliche kabinettsumbildung auch
cdu-chefin kramp karrenbauer hält das im
laufe des jahres offenbar für denkbar
die union müsse mit einem
zukunftsprogramm und neuen gesichtern
ins jahr 2021 gehen sagte sie auf der
klausur der csu landesgruppe in bayern
kramp-karrenbauer reagierte damit auf
einen vorstoß von csu-chef söder
er hatte eine verjüngung der
bundesregierung gefordert frankreich
gedenkt des angriffs auf charlie hebdo
vor fünf jahren drängen islamistische
terroristen
die räume der pariser satirezeitschrift
ein und schossen mit kalaschnikows um
sich wegen einer karikatur des propheten
mohammed vor dem redaktionsgebäude
legten politiker hinterbliebene und
kollegen grenzen nieder
bei dem anschlag starben neuen
redaktionsmitglieder ein wachmann ein
besucher und ein polizist
unter dem stichwort schon zwei jahre
liegen danach eine welle der solidarität
um die welt seit oktober toben in
australien buschfeuer wie sie der
kontinent noch nicht erlebt hat hier ein
foto von kangaroo island vor der
feuersbrunst
und so sieht dieselbe straße danach aus
unermüdlich versuchen vor allem auch
freiwillige einsatzkräfte zu retten was
zu retten ist eine fläche so groß wie
bayern und baden württemberg zusammen
ist bereits vernichtet
aus der region umsatz hielt im
bundesstaat victoria berichtet normen
odenthal bilder aus der glut hölle
aufgenommen aus dem cockpit eines
löschflugzeugs und eine ahnung
vielleicht was sich da unten abgespielt
dabei hat sich die lage doch gerade
etwas entspannt mildere temperaturen
zwischendurch sogar etwas regen das wird
die feuer nicht löschen aber es gibt
immerhin eine kleine verschnaufpause
eine pause die viele nutzen um erstmals
zu ihren verlassenen häusern
zurückzukehren und zu sehen was davon
übrig geblieben ist nichts so lautet die
erschreckende antwort für jenny braun
mit ihrem mann floh sie in letzter
minute und steht nun vor den trümmern
ihres lebens es ist so unwirklich
ich habe noch bilder vor augen wie schön
alles war und jetzt das hier
ich kann es nicht begreifen es ist so
niederschmetternd
mehr als 2000 häuser komplett zerstört
eine fläche von fast elf millionen
hektar verbrannt schäden von einer
halben milliarde euro sind gemeldet aber
dabei wird es nicht bleiben hitze und
wind kommen zurück warnen die experten
der kampf mit dem feuer geht also weiter
25 menschen haben ihn inzwischen mit dem
leben bezahlt and require wird heute zu
grabe getragen familienvater 36 jahre
alt freiwilliger feuerwehrmann ganz
harter schnitt jetzt zum board norbert
da war hätte die funktionen eines
zdf-expertin großes thema oliver kahn
der torwart titan
der ist jetzt neues vorstandsmitglied
bei den bayern heute sein erster
öffentlicher auftritt als mächtiger
münchner macher und designierter
vereinschef will er die
erfolgsgeschichte seines fcb nicht nur
fortschreiben sondern noch eine schippe
drauflegen wie er selbstbewusst
ankündigte
in zwei jahren soll oliver kahn den
vorstandsvorsitz von karl heinz
rummenigge übernehmen und bis dahin will
er sich einarbeiten ganz
unvoreingenommen und mit vollem
engagement herzensangelegenheit bedeutet
ja auch immer das sehr viel herzblut da
dabei ist dementsprechend emotional das
gebe ich sehr sehr gerne zu waren auch
die letzten tage sportlich will er den
fc bayern noch stärker machen kam denkt
in titel national und international zur
torwart situation kann sie teuer weiter
als die nummer eins neuverpflichtung
alexander nübel als lehrling vielleicht
auch um solchen über alpha zu bremsen
der auch kann der einst berüchtigt
machte ich werde jetzt nicht durch den
meetingraum grätschen dass es ja jetzt
doch schon über elfeinhalb jahre her und
die geändert sich natürlich auch einst
vulkan heute besonnenes
vorstandsmitglied
aus in australien das von boris becker
geführte deutsche tennis team ist beim
atp cup ausgeschieden
die mannschaft um ihren erneut
enttäuschenden spitzenspieler alexander
zverev kassierte im entscheidenden
gruppenspiel gegen kanada eine 1 2
niederlage
die deutschen volleyballerinnen dagegen
sind mit einem überraschungserfolg ins
olympia qualifikationsturnier gestartet
gegen den em-zweiten türkei siegten sie
mit 3 2 diese bilder hat vor dem match
wohl kaum einer erwartet jubelnde
deutsche spielerinnen und ein
bundestrainer felix koslowski der
offenbar die richtige taktik gewählt hat
vor allem ist es mit der nummer zwölf
hanna orthmann die mit 23 direkten
punkten aus einer starken mannschaft
herausragt und daneben auch die nummer
elf die isa liebmann der 22 direkte
punkte gelingen und die schließlich auch
den matchball zum überraschenden 3 2 1
erfolg über die türkei verwandelt für
das deutsche team gilt es nun diese
hervorragende leistung in den folgenden
spielen gegen belgien und kroatien zu
bestätigen und die deutschen volleyball
männer die sind schon in der quali einen
schritt weiter die haben nämlich das
halbfinale erreicht ist doch gut so wir
haben zum schluss noch einen blick auf
die größte spendenaktion die allein von
kindern getragen wird die sternsinger
heute sammelten die als die heiligen
drei könige verkleideten mädchen und
jungen bei der bundeskanzlerin
die kinder zeigten dass jeder etwas tun
kann sagte merkel
im vergangenen jahr kamen bei der aktion
der katholischen kirche 50 millionen
euro zusammen
beim wetter ändert sich wenig es bleibt
mild und regnerisch die details hat
gleich aus dem verlies das heute journal
um 22 uhr 30 mit marietta slomka hier
begrüßt sie morgen petra gerster und wir
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen abend
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter über den norden
europas 10 sturmtiefs und bringen dort
sehr viel wind bei uns ist es eher milde
luft und regen der ankommt schauen wir
mal auf die karte sehen hier die
hellgrünen töne die allmählich ostwärts
wandern das ist eben die milde luft und
dann zum samstag kommt schon wieder
milde luft es bleibt also viel zu mild
für die jahreszeit schauen wir in die
nacht und da kommen viele wolken und es
regnet je weiter südlich dieser
regenwolken sich durchsetzen desto höher
die gefahr von gefrierendem regen an den
alpen da klar dass auf an der nordsee
sind sturmböen dabei die temperaturen
sinken dabei auf minus sieben grad an
den alpen und plus sieben grad im
nordwesten deutschlands morgen im
tagesverlauf viele wolken mit regen die
sich allmählich weiter südwärts
durchsetzen etwa bis zum main und der
wind der wirtin den bern kräftig aus
südwestlichen richtungen
an den alpen scheint die sonne
temperaturmäßig liegen wir zwischen 1
grad im südosten und sehr milden 13 grad
im westen deutschlands
die nächsten tage es wird noch etwas
wärmer am donnerstag bis 14 grad im
norden kräftiger regen
ja und ab freitag wird es allmählich
trockener etwas regen im süden samstag
jedenfalls kein niederschlag mehr ein
schöner abend